no oh [ __ ] oh then I scream from my mom
I really didn't do that promise okay
your alpha
Sisyphus
slight headache dude I would have
[ __ ] killed myself right there
Jesus Christ
are you there bro bro
bro this is funny you know you want some
bread okay
[ __ ] it's so dark I don't want to go in
here bread first
Bradford
right first camcorder
box
I got bread did you bro I got [ __ ]
bread for you
it's a [ __ ] deal you know
I got [ __ ]
there was nothing in here are you
kidding me
I went through [ __ ] hell for just
this you're [ __ ] you're not my bro
anymore you [ __ ]
I hate you I really don't you dare camp
out here
you dare
all right I guess we're gonna go here
then because that's when we got the
flashback
well not flashback but reminisce or
something apparently someone's sliced up
a girl
we're hitting dead girls in a mine
that's good you know I tend to do that
11:10 - foxes I might as [ __ ] well
machine parts Wow
that doesn't sound very pleasant Oh
Shayne's that's always good news isn't
it
why not
[ __ ] no why of course flames just lit
up when I appear it is actually kind of
cozy but if that [ __ ] monster appears
then I have nowhere to [ __ ] hide what
is this
I like it oh is this rust
this is a machine parts I don't know why
it seemed scariest [ __ ] through my
ever seen but where it is this reminds
me of the orb orb thingy I bet we're
gonna hear something walking these
change later it's gonna creep the hell
out of me what is this machine parts
starfish
open nice and slowly
why is there already lit up that's
creepy never good news all right we got
two parts I'm not gonna pick this up
this time I'm not gonna be that stupid I
know you're gonna creep up on me this
week is first in case of missing rod if
a full set of three rods is unavailable
there is one rod in the inner study
rooms which might work in case elevator
breaks down again unless it's absolutely
necessary always use the spare rods in
the storage before using amended one I
don't really get that but I'm gonna all
right where do I run if you I see you've
come from there I'm gonna run there I
come from there I got I don't really
want to run there but all right
we're cool cool bro
be cool I'm gonna pick this someone up
now don't scare hell out of me yeah
where where where where broke whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa I knew it I [ __ ] knew
it
I [ __ ] knew it
Oh God bro this is not cool bro
got my bro I do what great puzzle
they're done
all right so I
sure sure luck moaning that's something
Lolita's cool you know No
go away already you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] this game ah jesus [ __ ] christ I
was prepared for it 100 [ __ ] percent
and still it is scared the hell out of
me this is not good for my heart I'm
gonna get a [ __ ] heart attack
finishing this [ __ ] game
[ __ ] [ __ ] white wine we have done to
you easily as
he looks like that I haven't seen much
of him but it looks like that [ __ ] if
you seen that Pan's Labyrinth I think
the movies call looks like that let's
monster in that cake
movie for whatever I get are we cool bro
I was just picking up some stuff you
know for face equity wrong
you need to stream a machine park made
out of wood a metal I've seen part I'm
not sure what the [ __ ] that means but I
guess I'm done here bro
oh [ __ ] I thought it was there [ __ ]
yep check the corners are you camping
ain't Jeffrey [ __ ] hate the camera
bet that's gonna go dark [ __ ] you
hello there
Wow
we're cool right you're not mad you mad
bro
I have to say
I've seen a lot of scary movies I have
not putting many scare games either way
this is by far the most scary experience
of my life
no doubt about that
doubt whatsoever and still somehow I
push myself self through this [ __ ]
game
I don't know like the story and I think
the game please I know the gameplay but
think what am I saying
I just want to see what happens
are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
here aren't you
I'm just camping the corner
the [ __ ] was there
it doesn't have very heavy footsteps
which makes it difficult for me to hear
when he creeps up
where where
tell me [ __ ] where
my sanity's low what the hell
oh that's the triple dot excellent
I don't want to keep playing
is too much this is too fun
Oh
I'm alpha
it's [ __ ] like breath I'm the old
version where the move to pay works
oh Jesus oh Jesus Christ
everything is to see I just want to get
out bro
I just want to make a Roma
it's it's the end of that heart maybe I
should
it's too much
whatever you two
gives me the creeps
and I'm just the [ __ ] creeps like
diarrhea throw up period
whatever disgusting goo that can come
from for a try for a fluffer
[ __ ] ass
be [ __ ] late oh geez uh I don't I'm
not gonna bother reading there
I'm glad that's over I'm really glad
that's over
Jesus Christ I bet there's gonna be
something yeah
keep my nose bigger but there is no
shape using a parasol in the desert
as it happens it's imperative to
it looks ridiculous the shade worker
much less than died are you sure
all right so now we can enjoy the view
of the statute
it's like a [ __ ] loose
yeah it is
hey hey hey hey hey well I have to say
that those a lot of parts has been like
in intense like when I jumped in the
water and all that but this part this
part was probably the most scary one and
I have no sandy left because I didn't
find any oil in there and I lit up all
most of this stuff like but I kept to
the in the darkness for too long
probably hope we're gonna find some
world
I thought that you know I'm in the light
now like I should be safe you know it
should be reset or nothing but
apparently I'm not doing so well and not
doing that in real life either ah I
should really take a break I don't know
if this is gonna be timing for a good
good timing for a part either way it
will take a split-second for you so I'll
see you guys later
geez